good
the judiciary committee will come to
order before we resume our questioning
i'd like to welcome the newest member of
the committee jared Polis from the
second District of Colorado congressman
polish was just appointed yesterday to
fill a vacancy on the committee and we
are happy to welcome him back he was on
the committee for several years and is
back on now he also serves on the Rules
Committee and the House Democratic
steering and Policy Committee and that
our next meeting will even go into more
details about mr. polis but we welcome
him today and will be recognizing you
immediately for questions thank you so
much mr. chairman I'd like to draw your
attention mr. Attorney General to the
issues surrounding the regulation of
medical marijuana I wanted to first
clarify there's a memo dated October 19
2009 from david ogden I'm sorry familiar
with that memo the contents of that memo
is advisory to the states is still in
force is that correct that is still a
current memo yes okay thank you and one
of the the issues that was later
clarified in a min a memo by James Cole
is what we're talking about when we're
talking about caregivers who your memo
instructs should not be an enforcement
priority the Colorado Constitution in
article 14 happens to have a definition
of caregiver it's further refined in our
Colorado statutes and I wanted to see
whether I can get your assurance that
our definition of caregiver in our
state's constitution will be given some
deference by the US attorney general's
office I'm not familiar with a provision
but what we said in the memo we still
intend which is that given the limited
resources that we have and if there are
states that are that have medical
marijuana provisions and if you take
into account the the Cole memo if in
fact people are not using the policy
decision that we have made to use
marijuana in a way that's not consistent
with the state statute we will not use
our limited resources in that way and so
sure I don't know I assume that I just
don't know about that provision and
again yeah in case of Colorado we do
have definitions of some of the terms in
your documents in our in our
Constitution and I would hope that this
the US Attorney General for the state
would look at that now as you know the
Department of Justice that recently
announced the crackdown in California
now part of the issue there it's my
understanding they did not have a
functional state level regulatory
authority Colorado does have an
extensive state regulatory and licensing
system for medical marijuana and I'd
like to ask whether our state regulation
or thoughtful state regulation passed
with strong bipartisan majorities in
both chambers of our legislature provide
any additional protection to Colorado
from federal intervention well again I'd
have to I'm not familiar with it but I
have to look at it but but again our
thought was that we're a state has taken
a position as a pass to law and people
are acting in conformity with the law
not abusing the law but acting in
conformity with it and again given our
limited resources that would not be an
enforcement priority for the Justice
Department thank you I'm grateful for
that clarification one of the issues
that many of the legal regulated medical
marijuana shops and dispensaries in
Colorado brought to my attention is
their inability to open bank state bank
accounts at most FDIC institutions that
makes the industry harder for the state
to chat to attract attacks to regulate
and in fact makes it prone to robberies
because it becomes a cash business as
well is there any intention of the
Department of Justice to prosecute
bankers for doing business with licensed
and regulated medical marijuana
providers in the States again I only
think the consistent with our the notion
that how we use our limited resources
again if the bankers the people seeking
to make the deposits are acting in
conformity with state law that would not
again be an enforcement priority for for
the Justice Department thank you moving
on to another issue with regards to
internet piracy as you know the
Judiciary Committee recently held
hearings on SOPA Stop Online Piracy Act
I have many concerns with this bill
including a overly broad definition of
infringement as you know there has a lot
of content on the
internet in fact is an example on
youtube alone there's a hundred hours of
video that's uploaded every minute many
of this many of the videos that have
been uploaded contained some type of
rights infringement with no intent for
commercial gain I asked with substantial
new powers would be granted to the
attorney general's office under SOPA
what type of resources with the
Department of Justice need to handle the
hundreds of millions of prosecutions
that would be necessary and indicated
under SOPA well I mean I think that you
have to look at what the what powers we
would be granted and then how we would
use our resources not every matter
though it might be a technical violation
of a statute is something that we are
going to use our resources going against
I mean if there's a Youtube upload of
something that is not intended for
commercial use and we don't think there
is any great harm that's not the kind of
[ __ ] are going to be going at it so
it's fair to say given otherwise the
absence of tens or hundreds of billions
of dollars of resources to go after
everybody there would be selective
enforcement of the Stop Online Piracy
Act from the attorney general's office
well selective enforcement always you
know a prosecutor get a little a little
nervous saying that phrase but there
would be an appropriate use of our
resources taking into account what the
harm is and always with the thought that
what we're trying to do is to protect
the abuse of copyrighted material thank
the gentleman and just note that with
regard to the selective enforcement
there's not currently criteria in the
bill so that would be at the discretion
of your office to decide what type of
selective enforcement of that law and
the new powers would be given to the
Attorney General under that would entail
and I'll yield back the balance of my
time okay thank you mr. Coe is the
gentleman from South Carolina mr. Gowdy
Thank You mr. chairman mr. holder
assistant attorney general Ronald
White's wrote a letter to a member of
Congress februari 2011 a letter which
was demonstrably false your department
withdrew that letter 10 months later
when did you learn that that letter was
false well I would not characterize the
letter his fault i'd say it contained
inaccuracies well mr. turn general it
contained material demonstrably false
statements agreed no you don't think
they're demonstrable false when you
represent that ATF makes an effort to
interdict all weapons go into Mexico you
don't think that's demonstrable fault
not in the way you use the word you said
well how do you know what way I use the
word I'm listening to you it is it false
can I demonstrate that it's false well
you said materially false now you're
using legal terms there you're a lawyer
and so you're now wearing that we're in
that realm and you said materially false
and that's a fundamentally different
thing all right well do you think it was
demonstrable false I would say that it
was inaccurate all right when did you
learn that it was inaccurate
demonstrable false you know i'm not sure
but i had concerns about it early enough
that in spite of the expression in
February fourth i ordered that
investigation in February the 28 and as
it was an evolving process as time went
on more and more information became
available and it became more and more
clear that that letter contained
inaccurate information well it strikes
me that if a statement that fault were
made to a judge you would have withdrawn
that statement that brief that memo that
filing the moment that you learned it
was false well there and I'm just
curious why there's not the same regard
for this branch of government that there
would be for the judicial branch of
government well if you look at what
happened over the course of months
between the time of the letter until it
was formally withdrawn there were a
number of instances where we indicated
that we had concerns about what was in
the letter
a test in testimony that mr. White's
gave at one point I believe he says we
are not I don't remember exact
expression that he used but he indicated
there that we had concerns in a letter
that I said I guess in October I
indicated there were problems with Fast
and Furious which was inconsistent with
what the letter said there are a number
of things that happen between februari
forth and I guess December November when
evidence that we like what with let's go
back to februari for because there are
at least four senior DOJ officials who
knew or should have known that letter
was false at the time it was delivered
your chief of staff Gary greenlar solemn
a map of Mexico where guns were being
recovered he was debriefed on Fast and
Furious he knew that cash was being paid
for the weapons in Arizona lanny breuer
you will concede knew for a fact the gun
walking was taking place in February of
2011 agreed no you do you disagree that
Lanny Breuer despite the fact that he's
admitted it knew that gun walking was
taking place by ATF was turns you know
their emails where he admitted it in
October of 2010 in a congressman you
have to be careful here he said that he
knew about gun walking in operation wide
receiver right which is why it's very
important mr. White's didn't say fast
and furious in his letter to Senator
Grassley I see where you're going with
that he didn't make a distinction on
Fast and Furious I'm just trying to be
careful here and I want to be careful to
don't want to complete thing I'm not
conflating did Lanny Breuer know that
ATF engaged in gun walking in February
of 2011 he knew that they had they had
engaged in gun walking in the fact in
the wide receiver operation so the
answer that question would be yes Lanny
Breuer knew that any statement that ATF
makes every effort to interdict guns and
not allow them to go to Mexico he knew
that statement would have been false
well he has said that he made a mistake
in not connecting that which he knew
about wide receiver and didn't apply
that knowledge to what happened in fact
what about Jason Weinstein and James
trusty this is their email exchange it's
a tricky case given
of guns that have walked that's October
2 2010 trusty response is not going to
be any surprise that a bunch of us guns
are being used in Mexico so I'm not sure
how much grief when we get four gun
walking these aren't a USA's in Arizona
these aren't rogue ATF agents these are
senior DOJ officials and I cannot
believe that that they just learned
recently that a demonstrable false
letter had been mailed to a member of
Congress why not correct at the moment
you realized that it was wrong well they
admit that they made mistakes with
regard to what their level of knowledge
was and what they should have done in
the preparation of the letter they
relied on people who they thought had
the best knowledge in Arizona and did
not bring into their calculation
information that they had previously had
about the gun walking that had occurred
in that prior operation but mr. Attorney
General you brought several law
enforcement officials with you today and
I salute their service it just strikes
me and I'm quite confident I'll get this
question when I go back home when law
enforcement officers a lot of lawyers
they go to jail when the lawyers lie to
Congress they seem to get promoted
there's a Border Patrol agent who is on
his way to federal prison right now on a
1001 conviction what consequences can we
expect because of false statements made
to Congress jimin's time has expired
that the Attorney General respond to the
question as I said there is an inspector
general investigation that is underway
I'll look at the results of that
investigation but I also be looking to
see what happened with regard to
creation of that letter if there's any
more information that I can glean on my
own before making determinations as to
how people will be held accountable for
the mistakes that that they make and
taking into account in making that
determination what roles have they
played in the department what good
things have they done I mean one cannot
look at these mistakes I think in
isolation one has to look at the
totality of the person service to the
department and then that basis make a
determined
as to what the appropriate sanction will
be and that's what I'll do mature when I
would ask unanimous consent for 15
seconds just so I can follow up on one
point and chillin continues to be
recognized for 15 seconds mr. attorney
general it just seems to me that the
policy is now going to be let's get the
least knowledgeable person that we can
to write the letter i found the exchange
between you and chairman Sensenbrenner
to be interesting on mens rea the
defense is that mr. white didn't know
what he didn't know so we're going to
get the least knowledgeable person in
the Department of Justice to write the
letters to members of Congress is that
what we can expect from now on no what
you can expect from this department of
justice as long as I'm the attorney
general is that we will do our best to
get you accurate information as quickly
as we can and actually think that one of
the problems with regard to the fast and
furious response is that we were rushed
that people although if you look at you
know that email all those emails that we
sent around you see that people are
really interacting with one another
trying to find information but I think
there was a time pressure there it
frankly they should not have allowed in
the process they should have taken more
time sent a placeholder response or
something like that and if it took two
weeks to get a response back to Congress
that would have been better than I think
the four or five days that it took I
think that is it certainly one of the
problems and there was a lesson learned
thank you Miss Chairman Thank You mr.
Gowdy the gentleman from Florida mr.
Deutsch is recognized Thank You mr.
chairman General Holder welcome thank
you for spending the day with us thank
you for your candid responses i would i
would note that sometimes facts get in
the way of political theatrics and i
appreciate your willingness to share
facts with us today i'd like to just
revisit this discussion by taking a step
back for a minute general can you since
we've we've delved into the weeds can we
back up for a second when did you when
did you learn about Operation Fast and
Furious sometimes the beginning of the
year it was it would have been I think
after i got those letters from Senator
Grassley on January the 31st and at some
point after that I think sometime in
February I first heard about Operation
Fast and Furious and what what did you
tell the US Attorneys offices what what
no
did you send them when you learned of
this after I ordered the inspector
general investigation in march i sent a
directive to all of the US Attorneys
offices that gun walking was not
acceptable not an acceptable technique
or tactic that it was contrary to DOJ
policy i had the Deputy Attorney General
send that out to all of the US
Attorney's and that that was after you
order the investigation and tell me
about the investigation that you ordered
the order of the investigation was on
februari the 28th i thought that i was
getting conflicting information from
people within the department of justice
and what i was reading in the media and
frankly what Congress was bringing to my
attention and it just seemed to me that
i needed to have a find out mechanism to
finally resolve what these conflicting
positions and as a result i ordered the
i asked the inspector general to engage
in this investigation what's and what's
the the time frame of that investigation
I'm not sure they are I know they are
feverishly working on it when it will
actually be completed I don't know I
appreciate that there are 64 thousand
guns and in Mexico is the number that I
understand ninety-five percent of the
weapons recovered from murders in Mexico
ninety-five percent were traced to the
United States tens of thousands of
weapons were traced to the United States
it is this discussion is is vitally
important but i think it's equally
important for us to broaden the
discussion two to one of how to address
the fact that there are still tens of
thousands of weapons that are winding up
in mexico from our border can you speak
general to the actions that Congress can
take in order to help stem that that
flow of guns well i think certainly if
Congress were supportive of our funding
requests to help ATF with these these
teams that we would like to send to the
border we try to send 14 at one point i
think we only send seven or eight
because of funding problems these ATF
teams that
have an ability to monitor the
trafficking of weapons into Mexico that
would be helpful there is a trafficking
statute if Congress would pass that
considering past that I think that could
help us as well support for that
regulation that we put in place that
deals with long guns and the sale of
them over the course of you know a
five-day period all these things I think
would be would be helpful and I a more
protracted dialogue about what the
nature of the problem is which is a
national security threat to the United
States you know it it's not only the
executive branch that has ideas that I
think could be useful i'm sure they're
great ideas in congress as well in to
the extent that we can identify them
work on them and do so in a way that's
respectful of and consistent with the
Second Amendment I think that would be
very useful I agree i also would suggest
general that it's worth broadening the
this debate to do within our own borders
as well i think it is worth noting that
a hundred thousand people a year in
america are involved are shot and gun
violence thirty-two thousand died from
gun violence last year twenty thousand
American children's and teens are shot
every year involved in gun violence
every day in America 270 people in
America 47 of them children and teens
are shot and every day 87 people die
from gun violence in this country we
this is a very important hearing and
this is an important discussion about
this this operation the investigation
that you've started I think
unfortunately the debate that we're not
having often enough here is one about
gun violence in this country is one that
acknowledges the fact that law
enforcement officers in our country now
need to carry assault weapons themselves
in order to match the firepower of the
criminals who carry assault weapons
there was a survey done of about two
dozen police departments by the
International Association of Chiefs of
Police that since 2004 all of the
agencies have either added assault
weapons to patrol units or replaced
existing weapons with military-style
assault rifles military-style assault
weapons are
now necessary they're needed by our
police officers because assault weapons
are flowing freely within our own
borders and while this discussion is
important we live in a country where the
assault weapon ban has expired and we
see assault weapons now flowing through
the streets causing our law enforcement
have to carry assault weapons the gun
show loophole continues to exist and it
is about time and I say this only
rhetorically I don't ask for your
response general but it is about time
that we focus as a congress on the steps
that we need to take to decrease gun
violence in this country and to get
these assault weapons that are created
for the sole purpose of killing people
off of our streets once and for all I
very much appreciate your being here I
appreciate this exchange general thanks
so much for coming thank you thank you
mr. Deutsch the gentleman from Florida
mr. Ross is recognizable Thank You mr.
chairman and mr. attorney general I
thank you for being here I know it's
been a rather long day for all of us I
just want to clarify your understanding
of your being here today because there
was some confusion I think at the
beginning is that your understanding
that you're here under oath that you're
under penalties of perjury as to your
testimony I'm here to tell the truth
sure okay so you are you believe that
you're here under oath is that your
understanding how much problem
technically under oath my I have an
obligation to tell the truth I need to
counter I'm here to tell out thank you I
hope so thank you now yeah I'm going to
tell the truth I want you to tell the
truth because I want to ask you a little
bit about your management style all
right you know it looks as though that
you have not really been reading any of
the memos that you get on Fast and
Furious in fact I think that your chief
of staff can Olson has testified before
the senate judiciary committee that he
also did not read the memo sent to his
to your attention regarding fast and
furious and I'm just curious why would
that be and you learn about this
operation sometime after the first of
the year this year and yet it's been
going on for a year you're the number
one law enforcement than this
enforcement officer in this country and
you don't know what's going on the
that would make me upset if I was in
your position does it not you we got to
understand these memos that you're
talking about our weekly reports that
come to the office of the Attorney
General the office of the deputy
attorney general and they are statements
by the various components of what's
going on in them if you look at the very
things that we have submitted to
Congress that show what actually dealt
with Fast & Furious in those weekly
reports they don't indicate anything
about these bad tactics okay it's only
about fast and furious as if it's
somewhere in the line somewhere in the
line of authority you've been you're not
new to this you were in the the Office
of Public Integrity what for freaking 12
years actually yeah been Public
Integrity section for 12 years you were
Deputy Attorney General for 43 years
none of this structure is new to you and
yet there's somebody below you and not
your chief of staff because he didn't
read the members but there's somebody
who's reading these memos why are they
not reporting to you because if you read
the memos read them if you will read the
memos you will see and then that metals
there these excerpts if you read these
excerpts about fast and furious all it
says is that fast and furious
essentially is going fine we're
recovering but did you know what fast
and furious was at that time did you
know that it was akin to wide receiver
but not the same no did you know what
fast and furious was at all at that time
no I didn't know about fast and furious
until but should've been out here
shouldn't you have known no because fast
and furious is an operation a regional
operation there are all kinds of
operations going on right now in the
Justice Department about which I know
nothing because of the way in which the
Department of Justice is structured
there who specifically would have been
reading those memos do you know by name
who specifically would then one my staff
who would do who their names the people
who I'd whoever had the portfolio for
ATF if with regard to their weekly memos
NDIC with regard to their weekly memos
those the people in my staff who would
have had that responsibility making the
initial determination as to whether or
not there was information contained in
those reports that should be brought to
my attention would you agree that one of
the most fundamental principles of
leadership is that you can delegate
authority but you cannot delegate
responsibility okay that sounds about
right and would you be
than to say that you are responsible for
Fast and Furious operation as i said i'm
ultimately responsible for everything
that happens in the Justice Department
do you have any remorse for what
happened with agent Terry of course I do
have you have you spoken to their family
have you apologized to their family I've
had contact with the family that I'm not
going to go into the nature of my
interaction with them is between me and
them and I'll leave to them how they
want to if they want to reveal that
people on my staff in addition to me are
in constant touch with the Terry family
even apologized to them as I understand
it i will say that i have expressed my
feelings to them and i'm going to leave
you're the number one law enforcement
officer in this country and a law
enforcement officer has died as a result
of a batch operation don't you feel some
sense of remorse that you ought to
apologize to the family I feel great
remorse great regret and I have
expressed this to the Terry family I'm
not going to reveal to you in this
setting the names real briefly or not H
of the interaction that I've had with
the Terran then let me just as nice or
info open idea I'm not going to do it in
front of a competitor you haven't
apologized that's all I wanted to
establish now you also testify in your
opening statement that as you stayed
here that the using used inflammatory
and inappropriate rhetoric about one
particular tragedy that occurred near
the southwest border and an effort to
score political points do you feel that
somebody is trying to score political
points with this incident with the fast
and furious yes incident well let's just
say that some people have not let facts
get in the way of and you're here with
clean hands to say that correct excuse
me you're here with clean hands to say
that because in your opening statement
you also allege or you assert that for
example earlier this year the majority
of House members voted to keep law
enforcement in the dark when individuals
purchase multiple semi-automatic rifles
and shotguns mr. attorney general it
seems to me that you're trying to score
as many political points as you're
asserting that somebody else has has
done in this operation and I find that
rather offensive what I've said there is
factually accurate I don't have any
problem with people you know criticizing
me or the department as long as what you
say is factly based that's fine I mean I
understand that I'm a big guy i've been
in washing
for a long time the concern I have is
where things are thrown at the
department generally at me personally
that are not factually based that's why
I draw the distinction I see my time is
up man I yield back and thank you mr.
Ross the gentleman from Puerto Rico mr.
Pierluisi is recognized Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You general I'm sorry I
haven't been able to be here as long as
I wished had a parallel hearing I
couldn't excuse myself from but the
first thing that comes to my mind is
that I should commend you because the
little time I have been here have been
watching you and I keep saying I keep
seeing that you keep saying I as I have
said as I have said as I have said and
that leads me to believe that you've
been asked so many questions similar
questions and you've had the candor the
demeanor the patience to deal with them
and that's what we should be expecting
and we expect from the Attorney General
and so that's why I thank you and I
commend you um stay like that though
because this hasn't finished but I have
a couple of questions a couple of
comments first I am personally concerned
about the gun shows and obviously that
the straw purchasers and putting aside
this Fast and Furious operation which
you have already denounced and and you
put a stop to it as as soon as you
learned of it what else are you doing to
deal with this straw purchasers
purchases and and and the gun shows that
seem to be you know like totally
unregulated and and and so on well we
have tried to make a priority to fight
against gun violence and we try to
approach it in a variety of ways by
being aggressive in going after those
who traffic in firearms to go after
those people convicted felons for
instance who should not have access to
weapons to try to come up with ways in
which we keep guns out of the hands of
felons that's really important because
if you look at the number of police
officers who have been shot and
unfortunately died over the last couple
of years the vast majority of them have
been shot by people who were felons and
who should not have had access to
weapons and so we do a whole variety of
things to try to keep guns out of the
hands of people who should not have them
that's good one thing that bugs me is
that for five and a half years we
haven't had a permanent director at ATF
yet I see lots of vacancies there I see
them in Puerto Rico my district my place
forty-five percent of the slots are
vacant even though we have a huge crime
issue and an illegal gun issue is is
that affecting the level of resources
that ATF has I mean is this lack of a
permanent director affecting its mission
its ability to meet its mission yeah I
do think so I I think that internally an
organization runs better when a person
who is seen as the permanent head the
Senate confirmed head is in charge I
think people respond better although I
think todd Jones is doing a great job as
the acting personnel but beyond that a
person who is Senate confirmed as the
ability in the budget process to lobby
for his or her organization in a way
that a person who is doing it in an
acting capacity cannot there you just
have more heft within the administration
in dealing with Congress if you are the
confirmed head and I think because ATF
has been so long without a confirmed
head it has not had the ability to argue
as forcefully as effectively as maybe as
some of the other components within the
Department for resources going back a
bit to this operation fast and furious
i'm the first one who recognizes that
congress has every right to do oversight
on this issue and investigate and so on
and i know you do too but one thing that
comes to my mind is that the moment you
end of it and you did not get the right
answers from your troops that's when you
said I'm referring this to inspector
general and as far as i know the
inspector general doesn't report to you
has why discretion is her objectivity
hasn't been questioned so this is in the
proper hands and is there an
investigation ongoing at the moment and
and what's and another question I have
is isn't that your mother's operandi
when you see any potential irregularity
in your department isn't the inspector
general the place you go to to try to
correct it and then if there's going to
be referrals administrative actions then
they happen yeah I think that was I
thought that was the appropriate thing
to do I continue to think it is the
appropriate thing to do to have an
independent inspector general look at
this situation this flawed operation and
share with me and with the rest of the
world what her conclusions will be the
Inspector General in the Justice
Department has I think a deserved
reputation for independence there were a
lot of investigations that were done by
the IG during the Bush administration
that generated I think a lot of
attention and I think we're indicative
of the kind of Independence that the IG
is capable of doing when it was making
determinations about the Justice
Department in which the office sits I'm
confident that with regard to this
matter the IG will be able to
independently review this as i described
flawed operation and come up with some
facts upon which i can take further
action Thank You mr. chairman I ask you
know me your name is consent for 15 more
seconds it's going to Jimin is
recognized for another 15 seconds it's
before I I stop my time has expired I
want to mention to you attorney general
that I have requested that ONDCP
director Gil Kerlikowske the drugs are
craft a what I call a Caribbean border
initiative something similar to the
southwestern border
initiative and the reason is straight
forward we are in a crisis in the
Caribbean homicides at the worst
possible level more than half of the
homicides in Puerto Rico drug-related
the the situation merits particular
attention as similar initiative to the
one you have in the southwest i hope i
will count on your support the point you
make is a very good one the
administration has what's called a
Caribbean Basin Security Initiative that
is in place to deal with the island
nations in the Caribbean and the
problems that they're facing I was in
the Caribbean for four days I guess two
or three weeks ago where I met with four
heads of state a variety of attorneys
general and interior ministers to talk
about I was in the Dominican Republic I
was in Barbados and I was in Trinidad
and I met with as I said those those
groups of people to deal with the
situation that they are talking about
and as Mexico is becoming more
successful drugs are now starting to
flow through the Caribbean nations both
to the United States and then to Africa
into Europe and there are two American
territories puerto rico and the virgin
islands it's very true and the right
problem is one that we have to confront
it is there's actually that this is a
national security issue that we have to
confront King and thank you mr.
Pierluisi the gentleman from Florida mr.
Adams is recognized Thank You mr.
chairman mr. holder I'm gonna ask some
questions and I think they're pretty
easy guessing no questions let's see if
we can go that route are you aware of
1994 implementation DOJ was responsible
so I can't hear you to a 94 there was an
implementation DOJ was responsible for
the implementation of Kalia standards
for law enforcement are you aware of
that I'm not for the year but I
certainly remember Kalia yeah does your
agency operator clear standards or do
you just implement for law enforcement
agencies across the state country I'm
not sure we operate under them yes I
mean do you have that type of are you
accredited I mean your credit credit
other agencies are you following the
same type of accreditation guidelines as
agencies throughout our nation
I assume that we do yes you assume so
then you would agree that supervisory
personnel are accountable for those
people then the performance of the
people underneath them correct yeah that
as a general rule sure yes you know I
listened intently because I'm one of
those law enforcement officers I'm not a
lawyer or anything else and i also have
a husband on the wall over and judiciary
square i have a lot of friends on how
wall so so i'm going to come out at a
different area i take issue with you
saying that we're trying to make
political points with officer Terry's
death to me it's personal okay it's not
political one of our officers were
killed with weapons that were allowed to
walk that should never have happened I
have worked an undercover we never would
allow weapons to walk now I've heard you
say if we get this provision that would
the long guns then it would it would
help the problem is under fast and
furious it wouldn't have helped with it
those weapons still would have walked
wouldn't they under fast and furious
would they have walked or not yeah one
yes okay let's move on no one does not
necessarily preclude the other I mean
the fact is that under fast and furious
a flawed operation and about which I
have not tried to defend the Khandaker
Act I understand that is what under that
is young were they not have our hot
picture there's no question that the
implementation of that long run rule
will decrease the possibility that we
mr. or the tourney general what my
question was under fast and furious
those weapons still would have walked
would they not the West or now dictate
the weapons would went and into the flow
of Commerce because of mistaken
decisions that were made by people okay
let's talk about this judgment let's
talk about those decisions here we have
an operation you get memos on but no one
that you know your chief of staff is
reading those memos somewhere along the
lines somebody has to know something
because this is an operation that's not
just within our borders it's crossing
internet
borders so what rises to the level that
the Attorney General of our United
States needs to know what is it that you
need to know about that rises that level
that you have an operation crossing
international borders you now say that
you didn't find out about it until after
the fact and after our inquiries happen
after mr. Terry officer Terry's death
what is it that would rise to the level
that you would have to sign off on since
going across international borders isn't
one of them could you tell me what would
be well first of all you are referring
to be his memos they were weekly reports
well any operation is there an operation
that would rise to the level that would
need your sign-off well sure there are
things that I have to sign but not this
one the one that crossed international
borders no oh at the gentlelady yield
briefly can I answer the question first
the what one has to understand is and I
would urge you if you have not done this
to look at these weekly reports and to
look at exactly what mr. holder vice I
understand you had weekly reports and
I'm not guys I've got a couple more
questions I want to make sure I get them
in but I'm asking you and I ask you what
would rise to the level for you to have
to sign off on it because this
apparently did not you said you had
weekly reports that you didn't review
and your chief didn't review so here is
that's the question I asked and you said
there is so I'm waiting to hear but
while I wait for that answer let me ask
you another question because one of my
colleagues asked you about your emails
and you went straight to your work email
hardly anybody has that I'm going to ask
you a very direct question you have a
personal email account did you at any
time at any time email on your personal
account with Larry brewer or lanny
breuer and Gary greenlar in regards to
fast and furious ever
yes we that woman is recognized for an
additional minute so the Attorney
General can respond to her questions I
don't know I can tell you that I didn't
know would you check and get back with
us if you need some help I'm sure that
your agency personnel can get into those
computers well with regard to provision
of emails I thought I made it clear that
after februari the fourth it is not our
intention to provide email information
consistent with the way in which the
Justice Department has always conducted
itself the exception that i made that i
made in the hope of the justice
department would be seen as transparent
was to go against that tradition and to
make available deliberative material
around the februari fourth letter so
again right as in when you were here
before and ask you about a totally
different issue you are saying that you
refuse to provide that information is
that correct I didn't hear the hope you
talking same time I saw and please each
in have more time I don't I don't want
to cut off your time I'm I just didn't
hear the question previously in another
committee when you were here earlier I
ask you another question you said you
would not answer that question now
you're saying that you won't provide
those emails because that's not
consistent with whatever policy was
previous I'm asking you if there is
clean hands here will you provide those
emails to this committee I said yes sir
now I'm going to act in a way that's
consistent with all attorneys general
performing that's not my question
attorney general I you know with due
respect that was not my question I asked
you with clean hands would you supply
those emails whether it's work-related
or personal emails as they applied to
anything that do with fast and furious
and as I said committee yes or now as I
said with regard to the dust justice
department as a whole I yield back and i
am sure sure i'm not going to get with
regard to the justice department as a
whole and I'm certainly a member of the
Justice Department we will not provide
memos after februari for fourth and that
is a way in which we with regards to
emails I didn't ask memos I said emails
emails memos consistent with the way in
which the Department of Justice has
always conducted itself in its
what about privacy chillin his time as
he thought that the answer is no is that
correct mr. Attorney General no but
consistent with the way in which the
Justice Department has always conducted
itself this is not something that I am
making up in terms of new policy I know
but you use the word not I took not to
be no oh I said no I'm saying no but I
get consistent with DOJ policy I
understand it mr. tarun ki miss Adams
the gentleman from Arizona mr. Quayle is
recognized Thank You mr. chairman and
thank you attorney general holder for
being here I want to kind of go back to
the februari fourth letter as well that
mr. Gowdy was talking about earlier
because when we were looking over some
of the emails between dear J ATF and the
US Attorney's office in Phoenix in
trying to kind of parse the language of
how they're going to respond senator
Grassley's letter like him okay well
wouldn't like okay I'll get him that
better okay okay one of the things you
know just parsing the language and
figuring out how to respond properly to
Senator Grassley in the letter for me it
kind of looked like you were started
that that group was starting to move
into a not a cover-up mode but a mode
that that really is more intent on
language rather than providing a
straightforward response at any time
wouldn't have been easier because the
letter was actually addressed to the
direct director acting director Melson
wouldn't have been easier and do you
know or if anybody else knows if acting
director Melson actually just said hey
why don't I go in to Senator Grassley
talk to him brief him brief his staff on
what the operation is all about rather
than relying on somebody who did not
have the requisite information to draft
a letter that turned out to be factually
inaccurate that you later had to
withdraw well I think a couple things
they're acting director Melson actually
did come to the committee headed by
chairman Issa on his own and that was
well after the letter that's right
that's true but he went in there and
spoke to them on his own after before we
had scheduled an appointment with him so
he did that on his own but with
the formation or the formation of that
letter ATF was intimately involved if
you look at the email you will see that
you have people from ATF at a high level
here in Washington as well as ATF people
in the field who were involved in the
interaction the goat the back and forth
of that email traffic trying to get
accurate information to send back to
that congressional inquiry yeah and I
would just saying sometimes it is just
easier to just have a short briefing in
I don't know if did did the acting
director offer to go and meet with
Senator Grassley at that time and then
was he rebuffed and told not to do that
no I was not no I think what we were
doing was responding to a letter that
was sent to us and that expected a
letter back in response well it did say
briefing I'm just I'm just curious
because I thought that would probably be
the most efficient use of time and
resources rather than the back and forth
of making sure that we have the language
right but the guess would be that having
the director show up would be the person
who would have to get briefed in order
to do that that tish that exchange of
information it's probably better to have
the people who are lower down and closer
to the facts be the ones who were in but
if you look at the emails you will see
that that was the case and in talking
about that letter do you know when was
the last time that the Department of
Justice actually had to withdraw a
letter that it sent to Congress I don't
know so is it a rare thing is it sure
it's a rare thing it's a pretty rare
thing so I mean I know that mr. Gowdy
already addressed this issue but what
sort of policies have you put in place
or structural reforms that you put in
place so that something like the
factually grossly factually inaccurate
letter that was sent to Congress doesn't
happen again and if it does that the
Department of Justice will act more
swiftly in withdrawing that letter so
that the members of Congress can have
accurate information well I think we've
learned lessons here and we've had
requests for information regarding fast
and furious since that time that frankly
we have taken more time
to respond to we have sent interim
responses to indicate that we are in the
process of looking at information
gathering information to make sure that
what we send is in fact accurate let me
get them since I'm this it is rare as
you said and it is something about which
I have great regret this is not
something I want to have happen on my
watch but I want to make sure that it
doesn't happen again people who are in
the department who involved in that
process and observed it I think have all
been sensitized in a way that perhaps we
were not before which is not to say that
people were cavalier but that I think we
need to up the game of our game and be
even more careful than than we had been
in the past okay if you were putting
into place other structural reforms to
make sure that I mean you've stated the
Fast and Furious was just an abject
failure and had fundamental flaws that
are put into place so that something
like fast and furiously does not happen
again yeah I think that if you will look
at all of the things that have been done
at ATF there is for instance now a
protocol that has to be followed at ATF
when gun trafficking is observed law
when you're doing gun gun trafficking
investigations you cannot lose sight of
guns you have to make a decision about
when an arrest is going to occur what
happened in Fast and Furious under the
new regulations and assuming that they
are followed it could not happen in
addition I have sent out through the
Deputy Attorney General and edik that
makes very clear that gun walking is
simply an unacceptable practice and I
know that you're aware of this but
there's a number of members of Congress
who have called for your resignation
over this and so I just wanted will you
be resigning over from because of the
fallout from Fast & Furious I have no
intention of resigning I'm the Attorney
General who put an end to these
misguided tactics that were used in Fast
and Furious and do you think that no
doubt about them i'm also the Attorney
General called on the acting inspector
general to say that this matter do you
mostly know it I just want to ask booty
the damage time has expired vs. 15 worth
the gentleman is recognized for an
additional 15 sec what time is fine yeah
if I could for this in my answer well i
was actually it was just a yes or no and
that's a that's fine but do you think
that mr. brewer mr. Grindley should
resign or be removed from their posts on
the basis of the information that I have
now no what about mr. Weinstein or mr.
Sisco if we're going down another level
Medina mr. cisco's over the White House
Council but do you think that they
should resign or be removed from their
the basis of the information I have
knelt no sort of figuring I should
anyone resign should anyone resign again
on the basis of information that I have
at this point no now there have been
resignation that have occurred unless
take those not you know think that
nothing has happened here since fast and
furious was was exposed resignations
have occurred people have been moved in
terms of personnel actions and as i
indicated i guess in one of my responses
to somebody the personal actions that i
have ordered our initial ones and i will
be monitoring the situation see if there
are other things that i should be doing
thank you thank you mr. Quayle the
German from Arkansas mr. Griffith Thank
You mr. chairman Thank You general
holder for being here today I just want
to follow up on a few points so my
colleagues had touched on today first of
all I want to talk a little bit about
miss Adams point that she was making and
that is certainly i worked at main
justice i worked in the criminal
division with assistant attorney general
Chertoff i understand how much paper
comes across your desk and everyone
else's desk and i understand that that
time is limited and you have to you have
to do the best you can to process a lot
of information i get that but I think
miss Adams makes she raises a good point
and that is at what point do you had or
has an obligation to particularly you in
your case with lanny breuer because you
have a close relationship or
long-standing relationship with them at
what point is there an obligation for
one of these senior officials to raise
something like this to your level I
understand that they're in briefings you
can't read them all there's a lot of
stuff that my staff puts in my inbox but
they know that it for something really
urgent they don't stick it in my inbox
they call me they come in my office they
get in my face and say hey this is very
important so this is not just an
operation or this was not just an
operation this was in fact an
international operation if taken if
looked at broadly because of the
consequences of these firearms going
across a border and and that was that
was part of the plan so my question
would be at what point is someone
expected to raise something like this
knowing that if it were maybe Canada or
the UK or some other country or we were
trying to let guns walk we certainly
would I would think we would want to
inform them or work with them help me
understand what your perspective is on
that because it's some level at some
level someone has to walk into your
office and say this should not be
occurring and I want to give you one
more fact on that mr. Brewer indicated
that when he learned about gun walking
in early 2010 instead of calling the
head of the ATF or telling you he just
asked two of his deputies to raise
concerns with folks at the ATF and so in
light of what has happened who and when
should they come to you about something
like this no I think that's a great
legitimate question and lanny breuer has
indicated that the information that he
obtained about operation wide receiver
and the gun walking that happened there
or the failure of the mission to stop
the flow of guns into Mexico is that is
something that he should have brought to
my attention to the attention of the
Deputy Attorney General and I think
that's the kind of
Mason that in fact should be if we had
an instance where you had evidence of
gun walking either the assistant whoever
had possession of that information the
assistant attorney general people in my
staff that's the kind of information
that should have been brought to my
attention and as mr. Brewer indicated he
said that he made a mistake in not doing
so are there set policies on that now
I'm not sure they're set policies as
much as you know you've got to look at
this information and you guys know what
are the kinds of things that are routine
and need not be brought to somebody that
which is important I'm living on time so
I'm going to try to move quickly I would
just suggest that regardless of what
other issues might arise at the
Department of Justice you might want to
put gun walking on a list somewhere of
something that raises flags the other
question I see my time is running
running out I want to go back to what
mr. Lungren asked about earlier he
referred to a CBS article that talked
about using antidotal cases to support a
demand letter on long gone multiple
cells basically using a situation
created by the government to support a
policy argument folks in the government
want to make and you your response was
that that was somehow unrelated or it
was so far back in time that maybe it
was unconnected what exactly was your
response on that well mr. longer and the
statement the notion that somehow this
operation was used to justify the
request for that regulation is simply
not accurate it did not happen that way
the operation was conducted separate and
apart from any desire to have this long
gun regulation that that's simply not
there now so that this didn't happen
that mr. Chairman I ask unanimous
consent for 30 more seconds the chipman
is recognized with that objection for
another 30 seconds well I look further
down in that CBS News article and it
says that quote on january fourth of
2011 because the quote referenced
earlier was july of 2010 on january for
2011 as atf prepared a press conference
to announce arrest
fast and furious new saw it as another
time to address multiple cell on long
guns issue and the next day he emailed
Chait emailed new bill well done
yesterday in light of our request for
demand letter three this case could be a
strong supporting factor if we can
determine how many multiple sales of
long guns occurred during the course of
this case I know I'm running out of time
I just ask you to take another look at
that you may not have intended it I
don't know what was going on over there
but clearly some folks had what happened
in Fast and Furious they had that in
mind as something to use to support a
policy that people in this
administration more advocating for so I
just ask you to take a second look at
that this is this is an article in CBS
News a website yesterday thank you thank
you Miss chairman and thank you for
being a clearly an attempt to use fast
and furious as a way to bolster the
request for that long gun regulation
would have been foolhardy given the
flawed way in which fast and furious was
carried out Thank You mr. Griffin the
very patient gentleman from Nevada mr.
Amma day is recognized Thank you Thank
You mr. chairman and thank you general
holder for your patience to how would
you how would you describe your
leadership style I'm sorry how would you
describe your leadership style I think
I'm a person who delegates pretty well I
think I set goals that I expect people
to meet not a micromanager hire good
people invest them with the authority to
carry out that which I expect them to do
try to give them the resources they need
in order to do their jobs and I would
think that on the basis of what I being
in modesty I would haven't been able to
do over the last couple of years two and
a half years whatever it's been at the
Justice Department I think I've done a
good job in managing the Justice
Department do you lead from the front
I'm sorry do you lead from the front
yeah I think I do you know I don't ask
anything of the people who work for me
that I would not be willing to do myself
I work hard I work long hours as as do
they
Thank You mr. Chairman I would like to
yield the balance of my time from to my
colleague from South Carolina okay the
gentleman from South Carolina mr. Gowdy
has the balance of the time I thank the
gentleman mr. holder there were a series
of wiretap applications made to the
Department of Justice and fast and
furious do you recall how many know
several would you disagree with that I'm
sorry but several I don't know how many
but i have to say that with regards to
discussions of wiretaps there is a
limited amount of information that i'm
going to be able to share in this forum
right and i'm not going to ask you
anything that's going to get you in
trouble with a federal judge please
don't those applications are voluminous
they're long and there are factual
predicate Stu support the application
for a wiretap correct speaking just
generally and not be right I'm not
getting any trouble yet speaking
generally that that's act are you
convinced there is no discussion of gun
walking in any of those t three
applications again I can't get into
these have you read them I've not read
them but I can't who approves them whose
division is that that's that the
criminal division's in the criminal
division that would be mr. brewer no he
only approves roving wiretaps you see
the head of the Criminal Division right
but there are no roving wiretaps in
Operation Fast and Furious but there are
several wiretaps in wiretaps would that
have long factual predicate supporting
the the application I have not seen them
but I make that assumption and you
haven't read them so you can't say
whether or not yet another Department of
Justice official would have been put on
notice the gun walking was part of fast
and furious I can't say that but you
cannot say it either no I cant cannot
say the converse no I can't who does mr.
White's report to who does mr. white Ron
White yeah I guess when the Justice
Department truck probably through the
Deputy Attorney General to me well what
I'm trying to get at it your defense of
your friend Lanny Breuer I guess it's
some love
as admirable I just don't understand it
it took me a minute to get you to admit
that he knew that guns were being walked
and their scores of emails where he
admitted it he assigned a prosecutor too
fast and furious this is someone who
owned his own website boast of being one
of the best 100 lawyers in america he
knew the guns were being walked he
assigned a prosecutor too fast and
furious he forwarded an email to his
home computer of a draft of mr. White's
his letter and he's going to stick
around mr. Attorney General well you're
saying things he'd see what you're doing
what I asked he did not do before that
is conflating things you said I said he
knew about and he admitted to V knew
about gun walking when it came to
operation wide receiver but mr. hold of
the letter is very specific ATF makes
every effort to internet with interdict
weapons that have been purchased
illegally illegally and prevent their
transportation New Mexico is that true
or false that is not accurate but mr.
Brewer didn't as he indicated he said he
did not have anything to do with the
create he forwarded this letter a draft
of it to his home computer now it does
not take a long walk to get that he
forwarded it to his home computer to
read it I'm only going by what mr.
Brewer has testified to which is that he
did not think that he reviewed the
letter review the drafts before they
went out that is what but you agree with
me mr. truth would I get our order mr.
chairman with it with it the witness
should be allowed to finish the
gentleman from Nevada be willing to
further yield who's the gentleman from
South Carolina has the time I'd be happy
to yield to the gentleman from
California I thank the gentleman mr.
attorney general if there were seven
wiretaps and they were all approved
under the criminal justice committee
where a criminal the criminal division
certainly we would hope that between now
and the time you next appear you would
read them as would lanny breuer in
detail since he approved them through
his minions let me just go through one
thing that I have to ask you yesterday
understand we became aware please mr.
Attorney General mr. chairman raider
order the time has expired it's your
turn a general I didn't ask him Russian
I I simply said I'd like you to be aware
gentleman
from California has a time the gentleman
from California is granted an extra one
minute to allow the AG to respond right
there was no question here is the
question review yesterday mr. attorney
general we became aware that emails
between Lanny Breuer and the deputy his
deputy Jason Weinstein about Fast and
Furious in March timeframe that they
exist some of these actually all of
these have been withheld from the
committee will you agree to turn over
those communications in the March time
frame between Lanny Breuer and his
deputy Jason Weinstein March of what
year 2011 as I've indicated we are not
going to be turning over materials after
February's are you aware that you are in
fact by doing so in the fact that we
already issued from the Oversight
Committee a subpoena you were standing
in contempt of Congress unless you have
a valid reason that you express it that
you provide logs which you refuse to
provide for the the other information
otherwise you will leave the committee
no choice but to seek contempt for your
failure to deliver or to cite a
constitutional exemption the Germans
time has expired the Attorney General
will be allowed to respond we will
respond in a way that is consistent with
the way in which the Justice Department
has always responded to those kinds of
that's not the question mr. Attorney
General Ken regular order mr. chairman
please proceed mr. Traynor will respond
in a way that other attorneys general
have other Justice John Mitchell
responded that way to regular order mr.
chairman that was that call for I mean
mr. B it should be allowed genom a
petition same from South Carolina has
the time but I'm going to allow the
attorney drone do you have any further
response to that question but you're
doing to the question mr. chairman about
whether or not he understood that it was
in fact an act of contempt unless they
recited a constitutional exemption and
still had a responsibility to provide us
logs both of which they were refusing to
do in testimony here today general from
South Carolina's time is again expired
do you have a final response mr.
Attorney General is Adams ask me about
congresswoman Adams asked me about
political points the reference to John
Mitchell let's think about that think
about that it's
point you know as they said in the was
the McCarthy hearings at some point have
you no shame you know but in any case i
will say that with regard to that we've
made our point clear how we will respond
with regard to the question of wiretap
information as mr. Gowdy knows there's
only so much i'm going to be able to say
about wiretap information so reading it
should not lead anybody to believe that
i'm going to be free unless i want to
get in real trouble with a federal judge
about what's contained in a lot of time
mr. chair Thank You mr. Chandra no mr.
Chandra no thank you for your testimony
today with that objection all members
will have five legislative days to
submit additional written questions for
the witness or additional materials for
the record I ask unanimous consent that
the gentleman from Colorado mr. polis be
assigned to the Subcommittee on courts
commercial and administrative law on the
Subcommittee on crime terrorism and
homeland security is there an objection
if not so ordered the hearing is
adjourned
Jack
Oh
Oh